voi dei pop corn si passano tramite la
webcam si grazie
è la gt ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj oggi siamo su come
cazzi chiamo suo gioco iniziati per che
significa abbiamo bisogno di andare più
a fondo non pensate male siamo qua con
sasha
ciao sachs usa knight a tifà scegliere
un oggetto ferme o meno scelto abbiamo
una vasta scelta creare inglese la bella
chiave inglese
ci abbiamo messo tanto per sceglierla
conferma non so che joe ma sei anche se
le mutande ma cos'è ma x che possiamo
con le gambe guarda perché non solo
leggins no aspetta non ho capito che
stavo in un sottomarino e questo è bello
poi dormire viene dormire con me
facciamo più sei i poco eterosessuali
vieni tu sei una donna quei baffi ma
cronaca come sto facendo la cacca vicina
all eco la parola eccola eccola è
premier e cioè più barba di me sei una
donna sa cos'è sto problema il turpi dos
ok ok aspetta cazzo è mi fa vedere fuori
c'è un c'è un'isola sasha guida ragazzi
vi dico solo questo già fa ridere così
il problema che non parte ora sta
andando
allora vai io vado i motori da iodati
motorio dato doppio motore
adesso in questo momento dovrebbe essere
mediamente veloci teorie ma tu non devi
fuori e non vedo fuori quello provarci
ne sanno che noi ho detto mimì di
tornanti il torna quindi esci viper di
comandi o che guido e tieni questa
velocità per adesso ti di questa
velocità che figata
è bellissimo perché ci vuole e inserirlo
c'è la squadra c'è la squadra si possa
sparare devo solo capire come si il cav
h
ho appena investito uno squalo e anche
dato nessuna roccia per a sparare non
solo
no no ai a ci stanno danneggiando secco
ok ma che hai sparato come fa con lo
spazzatrice aspetta che dovrei andare a
ricaricare i colpi
ok veloce prima che ci ammazzino sono in
degli squali bruttissimi tra l'altro
aspetto ci sono un attimo un attimo più
giù sasch abbiamo 38 di vita
sasha ci stanno buttando giù sasha nodi
la saracinesca fascia ma allora spetta
che ci sono sono fatta no come sta
imbarcando acqua
bravo bravissimo più dove storia l'acqua
ok benedetto 10 morto ma perché mi sono
anche cagato addosso guardali ma cosa si
fa man mano si ripare così il
sottomarino
non ho la più pallida idea dai schifo
aspetto dovuto lear la coprì ma perché
non è un rischio al dio si stanno
incornando oddio che brutta cosa opera
visita morti siamo arti lascia stare
siamo morti
perfetto vediamo se riusciamo tutta la
partita dove certa gente
ecco entrato vano entrato uno ai commi
player come player arrivando qualcuno
sta arrivando
non è male neymar becco sottomarino
neymar grazie grazie
cosa era così pessima dai wolves divise
blu va bene lo showroom a manger monkey
man ma anche io so so ai pip
la gang non si fa ai pilot andrew matt
di velocità in the cosa cosa hanno
scritto nati scritto niente
sono senza parole avrà sicuramente non
hanno capito così senza parole che ha
detto ha capito aspetta aspetta non mi
sparo
bravo bravo sasha questo volevo cazzo
ancora dura un attimo timido ricarica di
colpi da thriller che cazzo sta addio
cercando l'acqua
ok ok sono morto io ripeto forchetta
eccolo riparato riparato problema è che
piena d'acqua ios e buchi un [ __ ]
neymar se dovessimo il meccanico nei box
l'imac
secondo la differenziata prima che
eravamo in due adesso era in quattro
cosa nessuno allora adesso si che ci
siamo ragazzi vi vedo carichi tutti
pronti a guidare vaio va dai cannoni cal
ecco ci ha dato un filo il bhutan sono
io che non è sopra non ho idea io ho
preso sottobraccio successo chi è che
guida chi è quel deficiente tagli che
non è capace come io sono tutto il mio
capo guarda ora come mick ago male bravo
sasha sono velocissimo no che cazzo se
mai arrivati in under sì che possiamo
uscire veramente sì sì sì sì sì
tranquilli
esci che bello oddio oddio che cazzata
cos'è sta roba
nessuno picchia picchia i granchi
picchia la testa insomma addio già con
chi gli errori nostri stop ai arpat iraq
i nostri che in quel modo come prima
ragazzoni seguito alle conchiglie noi
stiamo andando
io non riesco macché gioco è c'è un
tesoro c'è un tesoro arrivar iorio non
mi piace questo tesoro non mi piace
io via via via di quale sono morto
parchi a l'aquila come si fa e non si
può credere
era felice ok ok a cosa vi sta restando
così fa grazie ed è visto tesori ma
anche lui e mora come teorema che si fa
prendere la roba ti devi abbassare per
restare qualcuno cercò cioè sta roba
o mio dio c'è uno scheletro morto con
una rosa probabilmente aspettava la
ragazza che lo abbandona sociali per
farci uscire la presa che uscire dalla
grotta avendo rese 2 ora vende vende
resta che sto arrivando a vendere 255
euro che porterà mai io pago
sa che ora non c'è nient'altro in giro
ma io sono quasi manca una pista si può
avere una pistola con gli preme poi si
prende lo so ho cantabria colo colo
spezzacuori i soldi soldi soldi in mano
no assegni il mio culo sopra una bentley
ma io vicini che ho uno di vita e se
crepo che quando abbiamo preso tutto da
qua tuttavia noi non andiamo via tv a
mostri noi che c'è qualcosa qua sotto
si può essere rispettati ammazzo lo
ammazzo ti cena c'è una perla che c'e la
perla o belle perle oppure siano
presenti
andiamo via dato il bottino e condiviso
quindi tutto da maria è certo se andiamo
dai torniamo torniamo ragazzi abbiamo
fatto razzie bazzi e razzie fuori con
barconi ruspa torniamo a casa a
immigrati all'aiuto sembravano spagna
che dice perché ci sono colpe che che
sta colpendo la ea sparare il city
l'attaccatura più avrà da una minchia
può farvi entrare per me venire a vedere
file è occupato maione rientra tutto
com'è stato il porca eva chen emo il
caccia tissimo qua sarà discusso per
sparare anche con l'altro
l'esperto aperto e morto non consuma la
piovra la piovra attiva gli scudi gli
scudi al massimo 20 vari dischi da
soggetti a rischio di saranno cornice la
devi togliere devo dare una mano come ce
l'acqua dovendo cav h ma come era di
colpirla là dentro la piovra i colpi la
retro e poi ecco come il buco e poi il
perfetto
sto morendo tutto ok i missili sunshine
sono morta affogata nella sala brown è
uno sfigato
ok ce l'ho fatta visto liberato aspetta
di viaggio ed è riuscito e fai arrivo
sono qua scena di morto malice z è come
fai come ho fatto primarie bravo grazie
ok
l'aspetto che sto morendo e preparati e
sarmi come si fa poi fa deve accucciarsi
su di me ha consentito di me
cos'è cos'è c'è l'invasione di un
graffio mutante dentro quasi dove c'era
chiamerà il pilota a dire no perché il
mare vanno ancora chiamate tutto piena
di buchi ha caricati è vero i botti la
tv fa quanta gente era la richiesta
scusa madonna impossibile quanta gente
ci vuole sto gioco per non avesse capito
ma va invece doveva essere in 26 quale
ragazzi ce l'abbiamo fatta e siamo
andati sotto io concludo perché sennò
non noi siccome non moriamo mai che
siamo forti conclude quarti se non
vinciamo tutto grazie lo so che siamo
troppo forte i ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto coma senza piaciuto solo un
commento è un mi piace anche i vari
social che come guidata da una
descrizione ringrazio sascha premi
seguito in questo video e programmi
accompagnato negli anni venti e famelico
sott'acqua e noi ci rivediamo prossimo
video da ragazzi 2